it's good
[Music
] they want Colombia in it,
well you'll stick coffee and
that's why being world always active the
crisis that they haven't done for about 15 years
the production dropped enormously last year it
was a super low production
what made it terrified
[Music]
and that change  of the determined climate, well,
and all these factors that
coffee farming is coming to less than
that culture, the coffee grower is going to be
a memory
[Music]
and
all the variety of  climate that we have
hours we have cold dinners we have heat from the
sun
we love it because within it we were born
with that they raised us
maybe it had come from below and a
coffee stick I don't know maybe I am very much in
love with coffee I have ventured into
roasted coffee I processed it  the opposite I
sell everything it is such
that it is an art it became an art
[Music]
virgil
we have had some heat some
unbearable suns that did not exist
now they
can be the future of mud cold
caut  ivas is a yellow dust it is a
world that is drying up the leaf and
they all fall off as you can see here there is no branch
or anything on the dialysis tour they were time in
water upper part of the
whiteside project football peak then it has
changed in that we no longer recognize  with
absolute certainty as it was done before
when it's rainy when it's
midsummer when if it's flowering
we have to be aware of the
flowering change and that thanks to
climate change
[Music]
and on top of that a
few months ago teams of wild shirts
[  Music]
we live your life of life
[Music]
TV stores like friends
waiting
but not
[Music]
with the three factors plus states of the
country monk
performers who live here
like me who have lived all  life here
we have lived under the influence of the
rhythms generated by the economic activity
of the coffee after industry night in
tour install by carmen current
fer anayansi egg factory  big in
representing farmers panic singer countries
with 3
exports
[Music]
everyone here had a house in the
town and a farm and we all had to
do with coffee let's remember that
coffee growing supported the
country economically for many years let's remember that
coffee farming had cesc it had a
grancolombian merchant fleet it had buildings it
had many things we were the
country's and the world's record holders because we managed a
very good price
directing the day by the coffee
configuring which of rich Colombians is
trusted
while the witches trust
3  of the smartphones of america tension
[Music]
in effect climate change rating and trans
world wide only form with music for
the scooter of our
seasonal customs of capitals of palms or
dissolutions bad things and of the same hall
farmers john henry moore 15 20 years for
back
everyone around here we planted coffee
planting hair nowadays
we plant it at a loss
distracting night generis from
environmental code for the country lower density
mercantilists people love and
register very strong of marguerite
ypfb-transportation crisis big city nobody
one end of fibers 10m of
next school combi filter the sides of those
enthrone has rates of farmers with
strike before media low mate
morphine in transport at this base the
same country unless they form crystals
tourist figures speaking in action
crime do
n't even see
for that you need resources besides you
have the land here that got hot no
longer works well what are you going to do what are you going
to do you don't have  how to buy land
elsewhere or something like that you are fried and
now they are desperate for
us to plant again and have
shade again
but that today at today's costs it
is very difficult for a farmer to
plant these things
camps I started growing bananas
in a pod that we carry, we call it
here an intensive cultivation of bananas,
so we growers are the ones who  Because
we receive the least remuneration,
so people get tired, I mean, I am in
love with the land and I can put up
with it somehow, but there are people who
have their children, they have others, that is, they
have many responsibilities
[Music]
that is who we have lived all
life here and well we have had the
opportunity to deeply know
the coffee phenomenon
[Music]
[Laughter]